Episode six
is very, very important
for our characters,
quite epiphanic for Valentina.
What about you?
Wasn't it epiphanic?
Of course. Of course,
she likes you, you know.
-You just like me.
-(LAUGHTER)
♪ (SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
All Mia wants is just to play
that piano.
Like, she knows that maybe if
she manipulates you into that,
then she'll get it.
(SPEAKING ITALIAN)
You think
that you manipulate me.
I don't know
if you manipulate me
or if you are sincere. Valentina
doesn't feel seen by people.
That's why it was heartbreaking
that Isabella was with Rocco.
(SPEAKING ITALIAN)
And in fact,
Valentina breaks down,
-and in that moment...
-Mia comes in to finish her up.
-(LAUGHTER)
-Exactly.
(SPEAKING ITALIAN)
Isn't it so interesting
that this dynamic,
that you give me something,
I give you something,
it's known
as a male-female dynamic.
And there is this dynamic
between two women.
(SPEAKING ITALIAN)
(CHUCKLES)
For Valentina, to live
what she lived in episode six,
it's something that is going
to change her life forever.
I think that probably Valentina
finally accepts the idea
that a new life could be
possible for her.
The funny thing
about our two characters
is that we start off,
I am innocent,
and she is very explosive.
And then, eventually, we switch.
It's interesting material.
All of the characters
are really tragic in a way,
but they're really funny.
It's just exciting to play
a character like this.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Tanya. Absolutely.
-I love Tanya.
-She's the best! She's the best!
But she's hard work.
-Hey! Thank you.
-Okay.
I think I would pick
an easy person.
Maybe I'll go with Albie.
He's okay with everything.
(CHUCKLES)
When I'm traveling, I like
to drink when I get there.
Otherwise, I just feel sick,
maybe, on the way.
SABRINA IMPACCIATORE:
Maybe I could drink
during the flight.
Yes, a good glass of red wine,
yes.
I don't have limits
in my desire of traveling.
Beaches, mountains, cities,
I would go everywhere.
I think I love mountains.
I love everything,
but I love mountains.
Oh, my god, me, when I go
on vacation, I'm totally wild.
My idea of vacation
is following smells and sounds.
So me, I love to arrive
in a place,
and the first smell I like,
I follow the smell.
I am so disorganized, so I think
I can't plan anything.
So when I travel, I just go
with the flow.